- Well, last time you were here,
you announced that you were
having a boy, so congrats.
So it was a Rocky birth, right?
It ended up being a.
- He was breech, So he was sideways.
And then we had to do a C-section
and I was just like, oh,
I wasn't ready for this.
And he came out with
some breathing problems,
but after like five, so
I met him over FaceTime,
but after five days we got
to take him home and he's so
healthy and happy now, but it was.
- That skin to skin time.
- I didn't get it. I didn't
get it for the first,
like two days.
- Oh, I will cry right now.
- Oh, yes I was like, it was really hard,
and I was like,
oh my God, emotionally,
I would have been.
- I only got to see
him over FaceTime,
and I was like, I mean, I guess, thank God
I have an iPhone or something,
but like miss him.
- Yah
- but like miss him.
- And like miracle that
they get to help bed.
That's amazing. But man
that skin to skin time,
even afterwards like
I'm just like lay off.
- Lay on me.
- Don't let go. Cause I'm like
- Yah they're so cute.
- And he's finally getting
to the age where he's like,
get off on me. I'm like no,
- And you're like prepare
yourself for life.
- Bury yourself for life.
- I'm here forever.
- You, recently talked
about your post-baby body
and people magazine, so things change.
And I know that happens,
but you did say though,
that you're really on top of
it. I think that's amazing.
I am still is loosing my baby weight.
- I am. I did not go right back.
- I lost all my baby weight
and then some which is like
incredible.
- That's awesome
- Cause I was working hard
- Yeah I'm not willing
to do that quite yet.
- Top chef. It was like, I
got up at five and worked out
and focus on my nutrition.
I've been like for my kid, like I,
I went on 45 minute walks
every day and I was like,
I'm going to work on my health
so that we can run together.
- I've never got really
depressed about that.
I think it's such a mat. We're magical.
We're amazing.
- We make humans.
That's amazing.
- Amazing.
- Central nervous system,
like incredible and brains.
We're like, I don't know.
- And you truly I mean,
for me, I'm already like,
let's go again,
- I love that.
lets make more even like
no matter how like scary
the birth was or anything
I'm like more, at least.
- Oh, Well, you, you love,
you're such a big family
and y'all are so tight. That's why.
- Yeah.
- Yeah that's yeah.
no, it is fun to have all
this then at least you get
all the diapers, everything
done all at once.
- That's what I'm saying.